what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode of our
beyond omega level series where we break
down the most powerful characters and
comics and with moon knight having come
out this week i thought that we should
cover someone from the moon knight
mythos and who better than moon knight
himself and of course in his normal form
moon knight is a street level character
and nowhere near omega level but we're
going to be focusing on one story in
particular where moon knight becomes
stupidly powerful the age of konchu
which ran from issues 33 to 37 in jason
aaron's run on the avengers of course i
like calling this version of moon knight
the immortal moon night because it just
sounds cool so in terms of his origin
moon knight was created by doug mink and
don perlin first appeared in werewolf by
knight number 32 in 1975 now originally
intended to be a one-off adversary of
werewolf by night moon knight proved to
be really popular with readers and was
given his own solo series in 1980 which
revealed the origin of the character so
moon knight is the alter ego of mark
spector who rebels against his father a
rabbi because he fled europe during the
holocaust instead of staying and
fighting so he grows up to become a
boxer enlists in the marine corps and
then joins the c.i.a later he becomes a
mercenary and then takes a job in egypt
where he's nearly killed by a guy named
rob bushman now mark is placed in front
of a statue honoring the egyptian god
konchu who basically visits him and then
offers to save him in exchange for
becoming his avatar on earth now mark
accepts and later becomes a superhero
and also gets exceedingly rich from some
investments that he made and creates two
identities steve grant which is
basically a rich playboy like bruce
wayne and jake lockley a cab driver that
allows him to stay informed on what's
happening on the streets now moon knight
is a skilled fighter in peak physical
condition and is proficient with a
variety of weapons he has a suit made of
extremely durable metal and he uses his
money to buy a lot of vehicles and
gadgets but none of that is why we're
talking about him because that's not
really what makes him omega level and
none of that's omega level stuff
beyond omega level the chevrolet
corvette so let's get into the story
that basically sees moon knight become
one of the most powerful characters in
comics now one of the things i want to
specify is that we do have this story in
its entirety although this will give you
kind of the quick and dirty version of
the story itself so make sure you guys
check out this card and that will take
you to the story involving jason aaron's
avengers run so this story opens we
basically end up seeing moon night in
kunlun which is the home of iron fists
and then immediately he tells danny rand
that he's there seeking the iron fist
and the two of them basically battle
which sees danny rand who's one of the
best fighters in the marvel universe not
only lose to moon knight but have the
power of the iron fist stolen by moon
knight's ankh amulet now moon knight
then leaves [ __ ] loon and travels to the
sanctum satorum the home of doctor
strange moon knight ends up attacking
doctor strange with the power of the
iron fist and then uses another amulet
to steal the power of the eye of
agamotto which is one of the most
powerful magical artifacts in all of
marvel comics and probably deserves its
own omega level video but moon knight
says that part of the reason he's able
to do this is because there is a super
moon amping up his power and already
moon knight has the power of the iron
fist in the eye of agamotto which
already makes him extremely powerful but
he doesn't stop there he then makes his
way to los angeles to the home of ghost
rider robbie reyes and steals his car
the hell charger he then travels to
wakanda with an army of the dead and
confronts black panther moon knight then
tries to steal the power of the black
panther but is unable to do so because
the power lies in the black panther's
blood moon knight is then confronted by
thor who vows to stop moon knight's
assault on the avengers but moon knight
is able to take mjolnir from him
effortlessly because the hammer is made
of rock that came from the moon and moon
knight is a servant of khanshu the god
of the moon and the plot demanded it so
moon knight uses the hammer to
absolutely thrash thor and then summons
moons from different galaxies and traps
thor between them we then learn that
moon knight is doing all this at the
behest of konchu who says that it's
necessary to save the world the one he's
saving the world from is actually
mephisto who's been imprisoned in a las
vegas hotel at the hands of doctor
strange now with his newfound powers
moon knight is able to destroy mephisto
without any resistance whatsoever as he
uses mjolnir to literally rip a hole in
mephisto's chest still this is not
enough for konju who takes the hammer
and conquers the world in two weeks time
enslaving the black panther for defying
him now later alternate versions of
mephisto from other universes attack
honshu in an attempt to punish him for
the crime of killing the main marvel
universe version of mephisto but in
order to defeat this guy for good konshu
decides that he will need additional
power from the phoenix force the star
brand which is a ridiculously powerful
source of energy and is really all you
need because your power matches whatever
force you're facing off against if you
have the power of the star brand and of
course the power of black panther who by
now has basically escaped konshu's
prison so moon knight tries to steal the
star brand power from a little girl but
carol danvers is able to save this
little kid at least for the moment
anyway shortly after moon knight goes to
the moon where he encounters nick fury
who took the place of uwa to the watcher
following the events of original scent
but nick fury informs moon knight that
he's basically been praying to the wrong
god but we don't find out what that
means essentially for a few more panels
in the meantime moon knight returns to
earth and battles a black panther again
while konchu now in possession of both
ghost riders hellfire and thor's hammer
seeks out the star brand now as he
closes in on the star brand he's
confronted by moon knight and we find
out that he's now praying to a different
god the god of the phoenix who has now
chosen moon knight for its host as you
probably know the phoenix force is one
of the most powerful forces in the
marvel universe and its power borders on
omnipotence and so imbued with the
phoenix's power moon knight is able to
weaken konshu who then loses the powers
that he's collected to the black panther
and ghost rider and so black panther
gives some of those powers to the other
avengers turning she-hulk into the iron
fist and blade into the sorcerer's
supreme which was really really cool but
after konchu was defeated moon knight
looks at the earth from space and then
contemplates what he's capable of doing
and for a moment considers purging the
earth of all of humankind in order to
save it but horrified that he's
considered committing genocide moon
knight realizes that he has to get rid
of the phoenix force and allows thor
who's escaped from the moon prison that
he trapped him in to pummel him with his
hammer which he recently regained now as
the story closes moon knight is left in
a crater on earth as the phoenix force
flies away and so that's how moon knight
a character that is definitively street
level
99.9 of the time became beyond omega
level four brief moment he was able to
defeat doctor strange and thor
effortlessly summon moons from other
galaxies and wielded the phoenix force
which is the sum total of all life that
has ever currently does or will ever
exist now in that moment moon knight
could have destroyed the world with a
simple thought and was actually a threat
to the entirety of the universe so all
of this makes this guy definitely a
beyond omega level threat but let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace